you
welcome back to CBS this morning CBS
News contributor Maria Elena Salinas is
here for this next story welcome back
right to see thank you great to see you
too
healthcare is a big issue in Nevada
ahead of its caucus tomorrow the state
has one of the worst healthcare systems
in the country according to a recent
report it was ranked last in the nation
for prevention and treatment and second
to last for access and affordability our
Series every state has a story focuses
on how issues on the campaign trail
actually affect people around the
country
Maria Elena spoke to Nevada voters with
conflicting views on health care so what
sets tomorrow's caucus apart actually
what sets Nevada apart from New
Hampshire and from Iowa is the voters
you know it's almost 15 percent of them
are workers they belong to unions and
the state is nearly 30 percent Latino a
union organizer we spoke to says that
voters here more accurately represent
America 31 year old yet linear or Dugan
is a mother an immigrant and a nurse a
supporter one of her main concerns is
health care medicare for all is one
important thing I think that most of us
can agree that even if you have health
insurance the cost can make it very
difficult she supports Bernie Sanders
and Elizabeth Warren thank you they were
on delivery nurse I see many women that
come in without any prenatal care we can
see issues with the babies that we
otherwise would have been able to fix or
prevent how do you deal with that
emotionally it's very hard rowan
Duggan's union which represents health
care and public service employees will
play a role in Nevada's caucuses but the
state's largest labor organization the
culinary Workers Union is one of the
most powerful forces in Nevada politics
with 60,000 members over half Latino it
represents most hospitality workers on
the Las Vegas Strip the bloc of voters
is so influential their union took
center stage at Wednesday's democratic
debate on NBC the culinary Workers Union
a great union these are hardworking
people I've been to the culinary unions
health
care facilities they're terrific what is
the most important issue for this union
in its members now that it's election
time its primary time the most important
part for us to protect is our health
care the union has distributed flyers
warning that Medicare for all plans
would threaten members current coverage
gioconda where Klein has been in the
Union for 36 years and his secretary
treasurer every human being need in this
era to have better health care but at
the same time we believe in choices we
feel very important to keep our own
health care because we had the best
health care in Nevada employers pay into
the culinary union's health fund which
supports their own private health center
for members and there are 70,000
dependents union members lean operators
who works at Caesar's Palace is voting
for the first time I just had a baby boy
I just had a c-section and then you guys
know how hospital that is right so they
don't really have to worry much because
I know that I was covered by my
insurance about a hundred and thirty
seven million Americans face financial
hardship last year because of medical
cost high health care bills are the
number one reason people take money out
of the retirement accounts or file for
bankruptcy all of the presidential
candidates have visited the culinary
Union to share their platforms some
seizing on the union's concerns we do
not want to take those benefits away we
have an obligation to make sure we do
nothing that would put that health care
in jeopardy you get to keep it under my
plan you don't have to give it up others
argue that switching to government
health care could help them fight for
higher wages employers say buddy under
our legislation workers get the
difference we asked senator Warren about
the union's fears I don't want them to
lose it I want to see health care
centers like that available not just for
the culinary Union I want to see them
available all across Nevada and all
across this country regardless of the
outcome this weekend Roy Dugan says
she's proud to be participating I think
every vote counts so my vote is very
important and I am encouraging all my
friends and family to vote too
good for her the culinary Workers Union
isn't endorsing any candidates at least
not during the primaries all of the
voters who we spoke to said that in
addition to health care they're also
paying very close attention to
candidates immigration plans they say
that two issues will help to mobilize
Latino voters to get to the polls both
this weekend and of course in November
I'm so glad we do the piece because you
came up over and over in the debate why
does the culinary Workers Union oppose
Medicare for all but now you get it you
know that health care center is
beautiful really nice they have their
own pharmacies so they said we don't
want to lose that you mentioned the
issues that will matter to Latino voters
how important will the Latino vote be to
the winner of 2020 it will be very
important and I know that for decades
we've been saying that the Latino vote
is a sleeping giant and that one day
it's gonna wake up well maybe this is a
year it's gonna wake up because Latinos
will be the largest minority voting bloc
in the country
with 32 million eligible to vote this
year and there are certain states where
the Latino vote will really be able to
make a difference especially in a close
race even some of the swing states yeah
Nevada Florida among others in Arizona
even beyond immigration health care what
are the other key issues for voters you
know it's interesting because Gioconda
the the head of this union said you know
this state really reflects the rest of
America and when it comes to the Latino
vote it's exactly the same thing they
care about health care immigration
Latinos around the country care about
health care and immigration only there
was a recent poll done by Latino
decisions together with Univision and
lower health care costs
protecting immigrant rights was
something very important to them and
education which has always been an
important issue for them but on that
list that we don't see here also is jobs
accretion of jobs and stopping racism
you know some people sometimes wonder
why when wonder when you hear this
anti-immigrant rhetoric they say you
know oh it's those undocumented people
or like they call them the illegals
which we it's not a proper word to use
them when you refer to a human being
because that immigrant that negative
rhetoric against immigrants also affects
US citizens with racism and there's been
an Inc
in incidents of you know of racism
around the country for adults and for
kids just speaking Spanish just a you
know having an appearance that is that
is Latino will make you a victim of that
so that's another big issue for Latinos
the Latino voting bloc has been called a
sleeping giant in the past because even
though it's large people didn't turn out
I get a sense talking to people that
they're more likely to turn out this
year well not just that but I think we
have the example of 2018 in the midterm
elections where the Latino voter
registration and and in actual voting
increased tremendously instinct just in
the battle alone there was an increase
of a hundred and twenty percent and
participate in voter participation and
mostly it was in Florida in Arizona and
in Nevada so I do feel that we have that
precedence to see that Latinos this time
around are motivated to go out and use
their voice and use their power nearly
vote in Nevada is already three-quarters
of it was four years ago so yeah even
more in fact real Lena thank you very
much it